many women are living in fear in
afghanistan after taliban's return to
power they remember how the regime's
strict religious laws prevented women
from going out alone and kept women and
girls out of school the taliban say they
have changed but the new government has
ruled that girls should not go to school
when they reach the age of 12. mts tab
is in afghanistan's capital where he
talked to the girls and their families
who are determined to resist taliban's
restrictions
it's time for school at the alfata
academy where both boys and girls study
but over the past month only girls 11
and under have been allowed to attend
classes while girls over the age of 12
millions of them across afghanistan have
been forbidden from getting an education
we popped into this sixth grade
classroom which now has the oldest girls
here can you ask your class if they all
want to go back to school next year
all of them
this group of girls all just 10 years
old tell us they're worried next year
will be their last in school yes i'm
very afraid
i want to go to school
i was scared these ten-year-old boys
said they also want to see their older
classmates back in other countries the
girls and women's can do anything they
can work they can study they can do
anything in afghanistan right now they
cannot do anything
taliban officials won't say why they're
banning the older girls but insists
they're not repeating the harsh rule of
their previous time in power when it
banned most girls education and forbade
women from going out in public without a
male guardian
but across kabul it seems the taliban
are erasing women and girls from all
aspects of public life even their images
once so common here have been painted
over but many girls refused to be erased
like 14 year old huda siddiqui since the
taliban's education ban she's stuck at
home taking online courses and with
every passing day huda says she's only
getting angrier i know it's a big
question but
if you could talk to the taliban right
now what would you say to them i
wouldn't talk to them you wouldn't say
anything
they're not worth talking to
it sounds like you're pretty mad at them
i don't want to see their faces
because they've taken so much from you
already
is one of afghanistan's most respected
obstetricians
the taliban have told her she's still
allowed to go to work but as much as her
patients need her shaftajo says her
three daughters need her more and
deserve the kind of education she was
able to have as a girl
do you feel like leaving afghanistan
yes if i have any chance i will leave
till now i decided not to leave
afghanistan because
i love my country a lot but right now
because of my children i have to go
it's a difficult decision many of
afghanistan's best and brightest are now
making
a brain drain they're calling it but
with the taliban breaking up even the
smallest of protests by brave women
demanding their rights sometimes
violently a growing number of women have
told us they feel they now have little
choice but to leave
i always think that i'm still thinking
the taliban really don't like women at
all they really they really don't like
us mabuba siraj never minces her words
an afghan american she's been a women's
rights activist for decades saraj says
taliban or not she isn't going anywhere
you've witnessed so many years of
conflict in afghanistan
you must have hope for the future i do i
really do i know that a whole lot of
them right now they think that they need
to leave but there's going to be a bunch
of them that they really do believe that
they need to stay
and
i'm going to be with them for as long as
i can as long as i have the life and the
energy to be what do you want to say to
those girls who haven't been able to go
to school
i want to say to them
my girls
my dears my daughters
just take a deep breath
don't lose hope because that is going to
destroy you more than you're not going
to school and you are going to keep
fighting for them
till the last the last
breath i take
i'm going to be fighting for them and
i'm going to be their voice
for cbs mornings i'm impeached in kabul
well it would seem they need to take a
lot of deep breaths you know it's it's
you'd like to think that the taliban is
changing but it does seem hard when you
think that girls can't go over the age
of 12 and to see them spray painting the
pictures of women just just eliminating
them absolutely i mean you're not
changing that much uh if that's the rule
right i mean that seems like the bad old
days just being afforded an education is
something we all have exactly right nate
i so admire the strength of the women
and the young girls that are saying nope
we are not losing hope that's very
important